607 on your Wednesday morning what's
driving you crazy well we do have some
signs of progress up in the speedway
poll remember we told you the other day
about an overnight closure this week of
the South 15 where it meets the northern
215 Beltway well the progress on that
project involves a different detour than
previous similar close remember how they
used to send you on to the West 215 to
lamb you had to flip a UE get back on
the East 215 for that short trip back to
the South 15. well the detour that
continues from seven o'clock tonight
until six tomorrow morning again on
Thursday night into Friday it now
involves the Tropical Parkway off ramp
where you just slide right back onto the
15 which you just couldn't do before the
other sign of progress is the reason for
the closure this Tropical Parkway bridge
over the 15 they are putting in fencing
to help keep pedestrians safe Nevada's
Department of Transportation says this
entire 130 or so million dollar cluster
of flyover Bridges connector ramps is on
track for completion before the end of
the year buckle up Drive carefully
please put on the phone you can join the
driving you crazy conversation at
traffic eight at eightnewsnow.com